um our next speaker is something of a
rebel i think
in the scientific community uh william
happer is professor emeritus in the
department of physics at princeton
university
and prior to coming to princeton he
taught at columbia university and served
as director
of the columbia radiation laboratory
he has some government experience some
recent and some
from about 30 years ago he served as
director of energy research in the u.s
department of energy
from 1991 to 1993 and then most recently
from 2018 to 2019 he was deputy
assistant to the president
and senior director for emerging
technologies at the white house
national security council
he told me at dinner last night that
he's more convinced than ever after his
most
recent service that there is a deep
state and it's much worse than it was 30
years ago
he's a co-founder of the non-profit co2
coalition which seeks to educate
policymakers and the public
about the vital contribution made by
carbon dioxide
to our lives and our economy and uh
i just want to say i'm also in favor of
of carbon dioxide
he's a co-founder of magnetic imaging
technologies incorporated
which specializes in the use of laser
polarized noble
gases for magnetic resonance imaging
he also invented the sodium guide star
which is used in astronomical adaptive
optics systems
to correct for the degrading effects of
atmospheric turbulence
on imaging resolution and i i'm hoping
he's going to
tell me at least what that means but uh
the author of more than 200
peer-reviewed scientific papers he's a
member of a number of professional
societies and associations his topic
today is how to think about climate
change
please welcome dr william happer
thanks so much tim
well i i certainly uh appreciate the uh
honor of speaking to this gathering uh
getting to know a little bit more about
hillsdale college which
of course i knew about before but not in
such detail as i've learned over the
last day or two
the title of my talk is how to think
about
climate change and let me see if this
clicker
works i hope it works uh good okay
so the first thing to uh
the best way to think about the uh
frenzy over climate is it's a kind of a
modern version of the medieval crusades
you remember that the uh motto of the
crusaders was
deus vult god wants it
and it's hard to pick a better virtue
signaling slogan than that yet
but uh so far most of the uh
the climate enthusiasts have not gone
that far some
have actually they claim they're doing
god's work
because decades of propaganda many
americans perhaps
including some of you here today think
there really is a climate emergency
uh those who think that way uh
in many cases they mean very well
but they've been mislaid by decades of
misinformation so as a scientist who
actually knows a lot about climate and i
set up many of our climate research
centers when i was at the department of
energy in the early
1990s i can assure you that
there is no climate emergency there will
not be a climate emergency
and crusades have always ended badly
they
brought discredit to the supposed
righteous cause
they brought hardship and death to
multitudes and
policies to address this phony climate
of urgency will cause
great damage to american citizens and to
their environment
but it's heating up on february 4th
bernie sanders and alexandra
ocasio-cortez
and congressman blumen nauer from
oregon and introduced legislation i
quote from blumenauer's website
legislation mandating the declaration of
a national climate emergency
the national climate emergency act
directs the president of the united
states to declare a national climate
emergency and mobilize every resource
at the country's disposal to halt
reverse
mitigate and prepare for the
consequences of this climate crisis
well there isn't a climate crisis there
will not be a climate crisis this is
utter nonsense okay
[Applause]
it gets worse when you get to the state
levels where there's a little less uh
checks and balances this are these are
remarks made last week by
charles izmay uh the undersecretary for
climate change
in massachusetts and it was made to the
vermont climate council
so i'll uh read it to you so let me say
that again 50 of our emissions that need
to be reduced come from you
the person across the street the senior
on fixed income
right there's no bad guy left at least
in massachusetts
to point the finger at to turn the
screws on
and you know to break their wills
so they stop emitting that's you we have
to break your will
right i can't even say that publicly
well uh
a few days later miss mr izmay resigned
uh and had he not his governor would
have fired him
but that's the way crusades are you know
this is really not a question of science
this is a question of the secular
religion for some it's a question of
money for others it's a question of
power for others but whatever it is it's
not science
so
during the medieval troops crusades
part of it was against the supposed
threat
to the holy sites in jerusalem but a lot
of it was against local enemies so
that the medieval inquisition really did
a job on the poor
qatar's in the waldensians of southern
france and the volga mills in the
balkans and climate fanatics uh
don't know or care any more about the
science of climate than these medieval
inquisitions knew or cared about the
teachings of christ
so just about everyone wants to live in
a clean environment
i do i'm sure everyone here does and
this is a photograph i hope it shows up
on the screen i don't see it just yet
of shanghai and uh
that's real air pollution uh
you can just barely see the bottle
opener building in the back through all
the haze and
some of this is actually due to burning
coal but a bigger fraction is due to
dust from the gobi desert they've had
this type of pollution in shanghai since
the days of marco polo and long before
and part of it is burning uh rice fields
the stubble in the fields
which is traditionally done there and uh
this is the kind of thing that i do not
support i wouldn't
want to live in a city like that and if
there's anything to do
that will make it better i would
certainly support that
but none of this has anything to do with
co2
co2 is a gas you can't see
smell or taste uh so
hair brain schemes to limit emissions of
co2 which is actually beneficial as i'll
explain a little bit later will only
make it harder to get rid of real
pollutants
like the pollutant i showed you in
shanghai
so um let's talk about
uh co2 it's number one it's it's not a
pollutant at all
we breathe out lots of co2
many people are surprised to learn that
they exhale about two pounds a little
more than two pounds of co2 a day so
uh you people in this room are putting
out a lot of co2 i actually brought a
co2 meter here
which i'm going to turn on it takes
about 30 seconds to warm up but we will
see
what the levels are before i came down
here my wife barbara and i measured the
co2 on our balcony
outside and it's about 400 parts per
million outside this building
so this is warming up now i'll show what
the results are here
in a minute but our breath
is not that different from the output of
a power plant
power plants take in normal air and they
burn
a fair amount of the oxygen out of the
air in burning coal or natural gas
or oil and the result that
comes out of the stack is mostly the
nitrogen that was already there
a little bit of oxygen that wasn't used
up and
uh water vapor and co2 and our breath
except for having a lot more oxygen so
you can give mouth-to-mouth
resuscitation you couldn't do it if your
breath was like the power plant
it's very similar to the power plant
it's about four percent co2
six percent water power plant has a bit
more co2
and a correspondingly less oxygen
but our breath is uh definitely not a
pollutant in fact our
breathing reflex is entirely determined
by co2 it's not determined by
uh oxygen at all it's not a lack of
oxygen it's
too much co2 that makes you exhale this
is a
picture of uh my wife barbara
in new jersey on a new solar farm
and we've just seen how well solar farms
and windmills work in texas
and they never did work terribly well
but that
we have to be grateful for nature she
seems to have a sense of humor
and has taught us a good lesson i hope
although people seem to be
slow learners but the problem with uh
renewable energy solar wind as they take
up a lot of space i
i preferred this field when it was nice
and green instead of these weedy panels
that's quite weedy now
this was soon after it was built uh
they don't work at all at night you know
so you need something else to provide
power
electrical power at night they don't
work if it's a cloudy day they don't
work terribly well in the winter when
the sun is low
uh so it's pure virtue signaling they
make no economic sense unless you're
massively subsidized by the state and
federal
governments here is um
an early wind farm in california it's
beginning to fall to pieces but
all wind farms fall to pieces they're uh
nobody quite knows how we're going to
dispose of all of this junk when it
no longer works it has much the same
problems as solar you know
when i was a kid people didn't sit in
front of
computer screens all day and uh look at
simulations of the world but you could
go outside and you know look up
at the clouds or what the weather was
like and
in those days people knew that the wind
blowed as it lifts us you know sometimes
it blows sometimes it doesn't and
we just saw last week it didn't blow
very much and when it was trying to blow
it was blowing home i stopped
windmill blades and didn't do any good
um
so renewable energy is really what i
would call the inverse
robin hood strategy you you've robbed
from the poor to give from the rich
utilities are permitted to raise rates
because
of the capital investments in
inefficient unreliable renewables
they junk fully depreciated coal gas and
nuclear plants all of which are working
beautifully
producing inexpensive reliable energy
but regulated profits are much less
so taxpayers subsidize the rich
who can afford to lease land for wind
and solar farms
the tax incentives pander to the upper
class and gated communities who can
afford to buy tesla electric cars with
subsidies from the state and
federal government often subsidies for
the electrical power to charge up
you know their toy and the common people
have little
spare income they pay more and more for
the necessities of life
in order to subsidize their betters
now um you can't spend a lifetime
uh as a professor and and not relapse
from time to time
uh to giving a classroom lecture so you
will have to uh
expect to be lectured to now for a few
minutes and uh
the the good thing is i there will be no
quiz
but as you try to those of you who
share my view that this climate is
serious nonsense it helps to know what
the
facts are so i hope i can arm some of
you with
the real scientific facts
this is a picture of the overall
circulation of the atmosphere
fear in the earth uh around the earth
and the thing that keeps us warm on
earth is the sun
everybody knows that things warm up when
the sun comes off but
dawn and it's nice and warm
at least in summertime and the early
afternoon it cools off at night
and the earth is warm mostly in the
tropics the
reddish area on this chart here that's
where the sun
is most nearly overhead at noon
and so there's more solar energy coming
in at the tropics and goes out
and as cooling radiation to space the
spun the sun
the earth also radiates and if you've
had
dinner here at the marriott you may set
maybe you
sat under some of the infrared radiators
and on the outside patios and so you
felt the heat
radiant heat you can't see it but you
can feel the radiation that's where
earth radiates out to space
so we cool our earth cools by radiating
out into very cold space
and by uh uh warming up from the
sunlight shining during the day the half
of the day
so uh climate involves a complicated
interplay of the sunlight that warms
us the thermal infra radiation that
goes out into space and the transport of
this heat
by both radiation and by the motion of
the air
and the water for example i think we all
know about the
gulf stream that carries huge amounts of
heat to
northern europe uh even to russia
uh and the these currents of air in the
atmosphere also carry a lot of heat
uh since we're in phoenix let me point
out that
if you look there you can sort of
estimate where phoenix is just
over the mexican border it's where
the color changes from yellow to green
and this is the descending branch of the
hadley cell this
this air that rises up near the equator
hot air moist air full of water so
tremendous rainfall down there and as
the air gets
really high 10 15 kilometers
most of the water has been wrung out
it's been freeze-dried out and
then it heads north or south and the air
that heads north
eventually falls back down to the earth
and
typically it falls down over phoenix
and over sort of 30 degrees north of 30
degrees south that's the great desert
belts of the earth that's where the
sahara
is and the chihuahuan desert and uh
to the south the kalahari desert
and so these are regions of earth which
are underneath uh
these cascades of dry air that was
produced
uh in the tropics at the equator and uh
naturally went north it's a giant uh
gas turbine but driven by the sun
and uh not spinning any uh
windmill blades uh at least at those
altitudes
here is a picture of earth's energy
budget i mentioned we're warm by the sun
about
half of the sunlight eventually gets to
the surface
the thing that prevents it all from
reaching the surface are clouds you know
other parts of
america like new jersey now are covered
with clouds so you don't get any
sunlight directly
and some of it is absorbed but the half
that does reach the ground on average
heats the ground and so the ground gets
hotter you
can notice that in the afternoon you if
you go out and
if you're a gardener like me you can put
your hands in the soil and it's nice and
warm
makes the corn grow um
and that has to be released if you keep
piling heat up it gets hotter and hotter
and hotter so it's released by radiation
to space which is that
red arrow going up so the ground
transports
solar heating upward near the surface
first few kilometers a good fraction of
that heat is not carried by radiation at
all is completely
immune to anything you do to co2
but once you get up to
10 kilometers or so most of that heat
transport
goes into radiation you know this
infrared radiation
i mentioned and by the way uh
i have this uh running now
the outside air is 400 and i'm not sure
you can
see this so i'll read it out to you it's
it's 580 in here
so what what this means this is not a
whole lot higher than the
400 outside during lunch we had this out
and it was a thousand where we were
having lunch
but uh but it makes the point that co2
levels are never stable you know
people are you know panicking about
one or two parts per million of co2 this
is uh
oh now it's at 608 that's probably
because i breathed on it you know and
you know hot air sets it off
uh these are interesting too you know i
i sometimes take it out on my back porch
and uh
you know at the end of uh summer day the
co2 levels on my back porch dropped to
maybe 300 you know
way below the outside here that's
because the trees and grass in my
backyard have sucked most of the co2 out
of the air
and then if i get up early the next
morning and i look at the meter
it's up to 600 so just from morning to
night co2 doubles
in the air doubles in half doubles and
halves at least during the growing
season that's
quite common and we have these uh
hysterics about co2 increasing by 30 or
40
percent yeah it's amazing
um okay so why why
the frenzy over co2 the frenzy over co2
is because it is a
greenhouse gas that is true co2
is a greenhouse gas this is a not
it's a somewhat uh
deceptive picture but what it shows in
red
is sunlight
and the horizontal scale on that top
panel is the
wavelength of the sunlight so sunlight
is typically
about a half a micron a half a millionth
of a meter
in wavelength that's
green light the color of green leaves
and the thermal radiation that cools the
earth is
is that uh blue
curve to the right of the upper panel
and that's much longer wavelength that's
typically around
10 microns so it's 20 or 30 times longer
wavelength than the
wavelengths from the sun and it turns
out that the sun's
energy can get through the earth's
atmosphere very easily
so essentially all sunlight or at least
95 percent
if there are no clouds gets to the
surface and warms it
but the surface trying to send radiation
back out to space
is unable to get it freely to space
because uh
various gases most importantly water
vapor
which is shown as the uh third panel
down
and co2 which is the fourth panel down
intercept
a lot of that radiation and keep it from
freely escaping to space so this keeps
earth's uh
uh surface temperature quite a bit
warmer than it would be about 20 or 30
degrees the earth would be an ice cube
if it were not for
water vapor and co2 and when i say water
vapor you should understand that i
really mean
water vector and clouds the condensed
form of water
so clouds are at least as important as
greenhouse gases and they're very poorly
understood
to this day
greenhouse gases were discovered uh
in the 1850s by this man this is john
tyndall
who was a uh anglo-irish
physicist working in london
and uh he was the first one who
discovered that
water vapor or carbon dioxide or ether
or alcohol
intercepts thermal radiation he
as is appropriate for a
anglo-irishman he uh his source of heat
was a tea kettle
so so he had this hot tea kettle boiling
on the stove and then
he had a pipe through which the
radiation from the tea kettle
could go and he'd notice that
certain gases like co2 or especially
water vapor
would block most of that heat radiation
whereas the normal
atmospheric gases nitrogen and oxygen
would not
so he we now call the gases that block
the heat greenhouse gases and co2 is
indeed
a greenhouse gas it's not a very good
greenhouse gas
at today's concentration so let me show
you that this is something i want you to
remember
this is an important slide so um
[Music]
there's a lot of history here and so
there are two uh pictures here the top
picture is max planck
and max planck was the great german
scientist who discovered
quantum mechanics and amazingly quantum
mechanics
goes back to greenhouse gas physics
thermal radiation just what we're
talking about today
and just what climate fanatics don't
understand yet a hundred years after
plant
but planck understood it very well
and plaque was the first one who was
able to show
why the radiation from warm bodies has
the shape
it has in on this picture
to the left of um plonk and below
shell i'll have more to say about
schwartz child in a minute
is a smooth blue curve and what that is
again left to right is wavelength or the
frequency in this case of light
thermal radiation and up is the thermal
power that's going out to space
and so if there were no greenhouse gases
the radiation going to space would be
that plant curve that blue curve there
and that would be the radiation that
keeps the earth cool
in fact that's not what you observe if
you look down from a satellite and we
have lots of measurements now what you
see is something that looks a lot like
the black
curve that's below with lots of
jags and wiggles in it and that curve
was first
calculated by carl schwartz child
whose uh picture is below planck
carl schwarzschild was a officer in the
german army in world war one
and he did some of his most creative
work in the trenches on the eastern
front
facing russia and uh
he in fact produced one of the first
analytic solutions to john
einstein's general theory of relativity
while he was there
you know on the front lines and alas
he died before he got home not from
russian bullets but from
an autoimmune disease which uh was
really tragic
but but anyway schwartz child was the uh
uh the theorist who figured out how to
calculate
how the real earth works with greenhouse
gases and it's those
jagged uh black lines
now the important point here is that you
notice there's also a red
line on this chart what the red line is
is what would happen if you double the
co2 concentration from today's level
so right in the middle of these curves
i'm sorry i don't have a laser pointer
here but
you can see a gap and that's due to
co2 absorbing radiation that would
otherwise cool the earth
if you double the amount of co2 you
don't
double the size of that gap you just go
from the black curve to the red curve
and you can barely see the difference
so the message i want you to understand
which practically no one really
understands is that
doubling co2 almost doesn't make any
difference it goes from that black curve
to the red curve and
on the basis of this we're supposed to
give up our liberties we're supposed to
give up the gasoline engines of our
automobiles uh
we're supposed to accept dictatorial
power by bernie sanders and
ocasio-cortez
uh on because of the difference between
the red and the black curve
you know don't don't let anyone
convince you that that that that is
a good bargain it is a terrible bargain
the uh doubling actually does make a
little difference it
decreases the radiation to space by
about three watts per square meters
uh in comparison the total radiation to
space is about 300 so it's a one percent
effect it's actually a little less than
that
and that's with no clouds clouds make
everything even less
threatening finally let me point out
there is a
green curve that's what happens if you
take all the co2 out of the
atmosphere no no one knows how to do
that and of course every
all we'd all die because plants die if
you take all the co2 out of the
atmosphere
but uh the what this curve is telling
you is the
greenhouse effect of co2 is already
saturated that's a
jargon in science it means it's done all
the
all the greenhouse warming it can
already practically
and uh adding doubling it practically
doesn't make any difference you could
quadruple it
also practically makes no difference so
the co2 effects are
strongly strongly saturated
now let me move on
you can take that tiny difference
between those curves that i showed you
the red and the black curve and
calculate the warming that should happen
i was one of the first to do this
actually in 1982. i
was the co-author of one of the first
books
and you can see uh on the right panel
there
uh is my calculation and lots of other
people's calculations since
the it's a bar graph of the warming
per decade that people have
calculated the red bar is what's
actually observed
and on the right is
i think for 10 years and on the left is
as 20 years but in both cases the
takeaway message is the
prediction predicted warnings which
everybody's frantic
about are all grossly over predicting
the
the warming compared to observation
which is the red bars
so the observed warmings have been
extremely small
compared to computer calculations over
any
uh interval that you look
so it's clear that you know all of our
policies are based on the models that
you see
here that don't work the models don't
work
and uh i think we sort of know why they
don't work
but no one is willing to admit it
uh here is uh let's see yeah
here's another demonstration again of
that the red curve here
on the bottom is the year you know so i
i think it starts in 1975 approximately
it goes through
uh 1925 because some of the predictions
so the top curve is predictions by the
international climate alarm
establishment
and the uh the bottom curves are
uh the blue and the green curves are
observations uh and so the uh
the the blue circles
are um measured by balloons you probably
know that
every day thousands of balloons are
launched around the world in
north america europe asia southern
hemisphere and they measure the
temperature as you go up
so we know what the temperature of the
atmosphere has been doing from these
really good balloon records and it's the
uh it's the blue curves
and the warming observed from balloons
is about a third of the warming that has
been predicted
you know by models and let me also add
nobody knows how much of this warming
that's observed is due to co2
uh there's good reason to think much of
it most of it would be there even
without an
increase in co2 because we're coming out
of the
in long little ice age and we've been
coming out of that since the early 1800s
where it got much much colder
and the green curve is measurements from
satellites
uh very much like the measurements of
your you know a temporal scanning
thermometer you can look down
from a satellite and measure the
temperature of the atmosphere
so the satellites and the and the
balloons agree with each other and they
do not agree
with the models this is a nice work by
john christie at the
university of alabama huntsville
okay so for the the
alleged harm from co2 is from
warming and the warming observed is much
much less than predictions in fact if
the warming is as small as we're
observing
it's almost certainly beneficial it
gives a little bit longer growing
seasons you can
ripen crops a little bit further north
than you could before
and so there is completely good news in
terms of the temperature directly but
there are
even there's even better news because
in reality by historical standards we're
living in a co2 famine today so let me
show you that
so this is a picture of our best
estimate
of past levels of co2 so
the vertical scale rco2 is the amount of
that co2 in the past was greater than it
is today
and so you you can see on that scale
that over most of the past co2 levels
have been
five times ten times even 20 times
greater than today
and during this entire period this is
from
this is the so-called phanerozoic you
know that
since the cambrian era when we have good
fossil records so we know pretty well
what life was doing during that time
from the sediments
and all of this period with much higher
co2 levels
you know life flourished on earth and in
general it flourished better when there
was more co2
so plants really would prefer to have
two three four times more co2 than we
have today
and you can see plants already
responding to that let me show you
uh an example this is uh
the greening of the earth measured from
satellites so
this picture shows areas of the earth
that are getting greener
uh over the 20-year
period i think uh my eyes aren't good
enough to read it but
it's roughly 20 years and what you
notice is that
uh everywhere especially in arid
areas of sahal you can see the just
south of the sahara
it's greening dramatically the western
united states is draining western
australia is greening western india is
greening
and this is almost certainly due to co2
and the reason this happens is that
co2 allows plants to grow where
today or where 50 years ago it was too
dry
so plants are now needing less water to
grow
than they did 50 or 100 years to go
before let me show you another example
of
what more co2 does in terms of making
plants grow better this is a picture of
dr sherwood itza and it was actually an
experiment done here in phoenix back in
the 80s
and so this is a pine tree
that uh i think it's a mediterranean
planet el
elderica pine and on the left is see
a pine tree growing in the current co2
levels at that time which was about
three ambient was uh 380 i believe it
says
and the the on the right are
more and more co2 so you can see that
the pine trees
the more co2 you put in them the faster
they grow and you can do this with
almost
any plant you know they corn is wheat
cotton they all grow better with more
co2
so this is the so-called pollutant that
you hear about with the climate
emergency
so let me explain uh the basics of why
that works
so um if you look closely at a plant
take a low power magnifying glass
you'll see the leaf is full of little
holes
and the little holes are to let carbon
dioxide
diffuse in from the air into the
moist interior of the leaf
where the leaf with the
a special enzyme called rubisco one of
the
most ancient enzymes in the world and
the most abundant protein in the world
combines the co2 with water to make
sugar
and the energy to run this little
factory this chemical factory within the
leaf
is provided by sunlight so
now the the problem with this is if you
see this hole
not only is co2 diffusing in but there's
a lot more water vapor inside the
leaf than there is co2 in the air
outside
so for every co2 molecule that diffuses
into the leaf there are a hundred water
molecules that diffuse out
so the plant has this dilemma
engineering dilemma it has to have holes
in its leaf to
get the co2 that it needs to live but
that
those same holes uh desiccated they they
dry it out and it
of course needs water to live too so
what is happening
all over the world now as plants grow
they they're not stupid they grow
leaves with fewer holes in them and so
there's more co2 in the air outside so
they don't need as many hulls but they
don't leak as much water either
so that's why you're seeing the greening
of the earth it's from the
plants themselves taking advantage of
co2
coming back to his more historically
normal levels
there's more to say about this there's a
second important issue which is that
the enzyme i mentioned is called rubisco
uh it's very old it was probably
invented
on the evolutionary scale three and a
half billion years ago
so extremely ancient and at that time
there was no oxygen in the air and so
this poor
enzyme was designed in a way that makes
it
poisoned by oxygen and so
plants today have a hard time when
there's not enough co2 in the air
this enzyme which is charged to make
sugar
instead of making sugar it it grab from
co2 it grabs an oxygen and it turns the
oxygen into
things like hydrogen peroxide and other
nasty oxidizing things you've heard of
antioxidants in your
tea they're to handle this problem and
that's why they're
generated and so if you have more co2
this uh
photorespiration is the jargon that goes
with that
that is suppressed and so plants grow a
lot better
with that there's a special type of
plant
called c4 plants which includes american
corn and sugar cane
that has partially solved that problem
but they don't compete well with the
old-fashioned plants as the co2 level
goes up
the old-fashioned ones without the
adaptation
uh out-compete these c4 plants
well you often when you raise all these
issues the hard scientific issues with
the
uh your opponents the the fanatics
the uh response is how can you say that
97 percent of scientists
agree that there's a terrible emergency
here that we have to
cope with let's see if i can get
this back again
[Music]
and so there are several things you
should say you should say first of all
that
you know in science uh truth is not
uh voted on it's it's not like voting on
a law
you know it's determined by how well
your theory
agrees with uh observations and
experiments i just showed you that the
theories of warming
are grossly wrong they're not even close
and yet we're making our policy
decisions
based on these theory these computer
models that don't work
so that's one point is that it doesn't
matter how many people say
there's an emergency if it doesn't agree
with experiment it's wrong
and it's definitely wrong the second
thing is
even when people agree in science
people think of scientists you know
somehow as uh
these uh incorruptible priestly uh
uh people they're not that at all they
have all the same
faults as everybody else and they're
frequently wrong a good example of that
was continental drift when i was a
student
in the 50s uh nobody
with any uh self-respect and geology
admitted to believing in continental
drift although it had been proposed
by alfred wegner a german
scientist in the 20s and 30s
and it was based on very good hard
evidence
an example shown below there's uh
the the fact for example that africa and
south america and india and
uh antarctica fit together like a jigsaw
is as though
you've taken the jigsaw apart so that's
pretty
uh suggestive i would say and secondly
if you look at the fossils
in these continents uh from 300 billion
years ago
400 million years ago they they go
smoothly from south america to africa or
from africa to india
or even into antarctica that you find
fossils of the same organisms
even though there's thousands of
kilometers of sea separating them today
and so that again suggests that these uh
were connected
but nevertheless in spite of this uh
quite persuasive evidence
uh wegener was scorned and mocked you
know all his life he died
falling into a crevasse in greenland
exploring uh
looking for fossils so sort of sad
ending
but he was absolutely right and um the
clincher actually came
when we finally declassified the world
war ii
uh north atlantic uh magnetic anomaly
data which we had
been sitting on for 10 years which
showed you know
a conveyor belt of uh cross being formed
starting
you know mid-atlantic ridge and and
going out
left and right toward america toward
europe
so there was absolutely no question that
the c4 was splitting spreading that
that's the one bit of evidence that
wegner did not have
but he had lots of other evidence that
should have persuaded people so
this is just one example i could tell
you many others of
scientific consensus consensuses that
made no sense this one
is interesting because it had no
political background it was pure science
you know but it does illustrate the
fallibility of scientists and the the
group thing
that goes in science you know if you
wanted to
advance as a young geologist you could
write a paper scorning wegner in 1950
and uh get promoted right away
even even though your paper was
completely wrong and one once you get
tenure you're there for
good so let me
let me uh this is probably uh a little
too long a lecture so let me
bring it to a close and i'll take some
questions so uh
so the uh takeaway message is that
policies to slow co2 emissions are
they're based on flawed computer models
which exaggerated warming by
factors of two or three probably more
that's message number one so why do we
give up our freedom why do we give up
our automobiles why do we give up a beef
steak
because of this model that doesn't work
and uh well number two is that if you
really look into it more co2 actually
benefits the world
so what are we doing you know there's
this uh
beneficial molecule that's making plants
grow better that's giving us a little
less harsh winters a slightly longer
growing season
why is that a pollutant it's not a
pollutant at all and we should
have the courage to do nothing about co2
emissions nothing needs to be done
so thank you i'll stop at this point
thank you dr happer we now have time for
some q a
if you have a question please raise your
hand and wait for a microphone to be
brought to you
a very interesting conversation
one of the things that the
environmentalists always forget
is the tremendous amount of co2 that is
produced
to get the raw materials to make the
wind turbines
to make the solar cells but another
thing that i have thought about
i've never seen it discussed every one
of those things takes heat
out of the atmosphere has anybody ever
figured that out the second thing is we
talk about the
rise of the ocean of the sea level
everything we put into the ocean
raises the sea level a little bit and
all of the mud that flows off
the land raises the sea level they think
it just comes out from
glacier mounting but there's much more
complicated than that
yeah thank you it's true that anything
you make
in our modern world involves co2
production or sometimes the carbon
actually goes into the product plastics
are made of carbon
you know my coat is made of carbon
um with respect to
uh the amount of that i i think
it's uh uh it's not negligible but
uh the biggest source of co2 is actually
burning fossil fuels to get energy for
all transportation mostly but also
electrical power
another non-trivial part is cement
making
you know the way you make cement is you
take limestone which is calcium
carbonate
and you have to burn oil or coal and you
bake that out and so you get the co2
from burning the
oil or cold to heat it to burn the lime
and then what
when you're burning it co2 is coming out
so the uh
what you do is you're baking co2 out of
the limestone
so you get a sort of double whammy from
cement manufacturer
i wouldn't call it a double lemmy i
would call it a double benefit because
as i've said
it's really good you know for life on
earth
you know plants love more co2 we're
happy with more co2 too we know a lot
about how it affects humans it doesn't
affect us at all
as for sea level uh sea levels started
to rise around
1800 at the end of the little ice age
and they've been rising steadily at
about two millimeters per
year two millimeters not very much you
can barely see it
well that's maybe nine inches a century
you know typical if you go to the sea a
typical tide is quite a bit more than uh
nine inches so if nine inches is going
to bother you you
you've been swindled in the real estate
you've got there
so it's uh nobody knows how long this
rise will continue
uh it uh could easily go for another
century or it could stop in a couple
years
one i was having lunch with someone and
they asked what's interesting
in basic science and one of the more
interesting things is
speculations that solar activity is
beginning to decrease you know if you
look at
sunspot activity it's definitely
less the last few years and we've had
these
rather cold winters the last few years
and one of the
possible drivers of climate is solar
activity so
if if there really is going to be a
cooling period we had a cooling period
for example in in the 70s
i remember then in reading about the
coming ice age and
newsweek and time and uh they flipped
immediately you know 10
10 years later so in physics we have a
joke which says you know the hardest
thing about a theory is getting the sign
right
and that's been true of that's been true
of climate for a long time
um anyway it could cool uh in another
10 or 15 years i don't have a strong
opinion but i'm interested in it
we have a question on the speaker's
right
i understand that the original idea was
that
co2 would cause a slight warming which
would cause
more water vapor which was the big
greenhouse gas which would cause still
more
water vapor and more heating etc
and a runaway situation the fact that
the earth
well that the co2 only its only effect
was to increase
the temperature and start that cycle
shouldn't have been kind of obvious
since uh
previously the earth has been a lot
warmer and it didn't
start to boil yeah yeah absolutely the
the reason the models get these huge uh
numbers and mine had the same flaw
is because of the water vapor feedback
and uh
i think the reason that those feedbacks
are are
overestimated uh and i've worked
personally on this so i know a lot about
it
is that they don't treat clouds
correctly at the same time you can't
increase water vapor without affecting
clouds and
just a few percent change in cloudiness
completely
overwhelms any change from co2 or water
vapor
i mean we're all familiar with the fact
that if it's a hot summer day and a
cloud comes over it cools down
and if you take that on a global scale
it turns out that there's
just exquisite sensitivity to cloudiness
uh just to follow up on another uh
illusion you made
if there really were this positive
feedback you can't look at the
geological history of the earth and
it could not be as stable the climate
could not be as stable as the geological
record indicates if there were these
policy feedbacks because the
the temperature would be shooting up and
down up and down all of the time you
know for example because of these
changes solar output i mentioned
but that's not observed the the earth's
climate turns out to be
remarkably stable you know if it
if there are feedbacks they're probably
negative feedbacks
and they probably involve clouds as my
educated guest
we have time for one more question yeah
i appreciate the
discussion and the knowledge that you
passed on but i when i look at this
issue though it's more about marketing
and perception
than science being retired i have a
chance to read these studies as they're
published
and i noticed a little trend where they
would
make a sort of scientific statement
about
climate change and two or three
sentences later then they go into the
projected
impacts coastal flooding um
deserts everywhere and so forth and the
media
of course only reads the first paragraph
or whatever or whatever they're fed and
so then they publish that and and it
just scares the bejesus out of people
and
i know i have relatives that believe
this stuff
and you try and explain what you're
telling us
and with new knowledge maybe i can do
that but you can't get through
these people they're just scared from
from the perception and the marketing so
what do we do
well you know that's sort of the key
question because i i
the scientific support for it really
doesn't exist
but the uh so many people are scared now
and so many people have been brainwashed
since childhood
i know i i watched our children and
grandchildren
in school and uh they get
incessant barrage of the world is coming
to an end you're unlikely to finish your
life because you're going to fry
and because your dad's driving an suv
and um you know
they're a fair fraction of kids who are
sufficiently
you know independent thinkers in every
generation that they laugh this off but
they're a lot
who take it seriously and they go home
they can't sleep at night you've got
greta toonberg you know uh having his
hysterics you know in front of the
mighty of the world
but she doesn't know anything the main
amazing thing about greta you know she
i those of you know a little bit about
the history of science greg is the great
granddaughter of svante arrhenius
and santi arenas was the first person to
seriously try to calculate the
effects of more co2 he thought it would
be good for sweden he was from
he was a swedish chemist and it would
have been good for sweden in fact it
is being good for sweden sweden for
example is getting much higher forestry
yields now than it did
50 years ago because of more co2
but uh i think he would be appalled to
see his great
granddaughter you know having hysterics
and
in front of the world for something that
he was convinced would be good
please join me in thanking dr happer
you